this is Watergate on steroids remember
the Nixon scandal it was about a
third-rate burglary this is a deep state
political hit job now spying on an
opposition party campaign FBI spies
during an election and it gets worse the
deep state isn't even trying to hide it
and what they did there now bragging
about it
the former Obama Director of National
Intelligence James clapper is actually
saying spying on the Trump campaign was
a good thing has he ever heard of the
Constitution we're gonna unpack all
these stunning new details tonight now
it will make you question how this could
ever happen in the United States of
America and also tonight a deep state
source smear this is pretty unreal
liberal media anonymous government
sources falsely accusing the president
and Republicans and conservatives of
actually endangering the life of an FBI
informant you know the one that was
spying for the FBI and the Trump
campaign do they have a warrant it's
also revealing critical information
about who this person really is and
tonight the Speaker of the House Paul
Ryan he is now telling the special
counsel wrapped up this corrupt
investigation now also tonight we have
sad news at a Texas the president
reacting to yet another tragic school
shooting we will explain why it is time
for this country to get serious when it
comes to protecting our precious
children there is an answer we'll
explain the solution we have that and
more in tonight's important breaking
news opening monologue
[Music]
five major developments again tonight on
the deep state spying on the Trump
campaign James clapper Barack Obama's
former Director of National Intelligence
is actually today saying it was a good
thing that the Trump campaign had a spy
for the FBI in their campaign during an
election I can't believe it watch it
they may had someone who was talking to
them in in the campaign but you know the
focus here and as it was with the
intelligent he is not on the campaign
per se but what the Russians were doing
to try to to instantiate themselves in
the campaign or the influence or
leverage it so if there was someone that
was observing that sort of thing well
that's a good thing
yeah where was the spy in the Hillary
campaign where she did pay for Russian
lies clappers so pompous so arrogant
this is so illegal he's actually
bragging about surveilling an opposition
party during a presidential election
year if that's the case this is not
America we don't have a constitution
this is something you'd expect from the
former Soviet Union Venezuela then again
you got clappers buddy John Brennan
who's also up to his eyeballs in the
scandal probably knows a lot about it
since remember he's the guy that voted
for a communist for president last night
we had the great one Mark Levin reacting
to all of this his analysis dead spot on
take a look we have a cabal of FBI
agents who took it upon themselves to
investigate a candidate and his campaign
and then we have of course actual spies
one or more in the Trump campaign what
the hell is this the Soviet Union
Venezuela it's the United States of
America I want to know what Brennan did
I want to know what clapper did I want
to know what Comey did not because I'm
going to punish them
you'll make determinations about this
right something something is terribly
wrong we need to fix this we cannot have
in another election where the federal
government our United States government
is fair interfering with an election the
great ones right we've been right
everyone on this program
have been right we need to fix it
because this is about the Constitution
of the United States and it's literally
hanging in the balance at this hour
you have unelected deep state actors
shredding our Fourth Amendment rights
your right to privacy protection against
unreasonable search and seizure this is
as I've been telling you one of the
darkest chapters in American history the
Trump campaign is targeted but there's
people like clapper Brennan Comey and
others they think that they knew better
than you did the American people about
who should be the president they've
weaponized the powerful tools of
intelligence turned it on us and they
are now politicizing differences
political differences and by the way
clapper since you're so concerned about
Russian influence in the election did
you have a spy in the Clinton campaign
now we know for a fact her campaign was
colluding had a foreign agent
Christopher Steele paying for Russian
lies and propaganda to lie to the
American people and Clinton in the DNC
remember they paid over what twelve
million dollars for the Russian dossier
full of Russian lies where's the FBI
where's the CIA where the spies of
course there weren't any instead of
investigating it well they used former
spy Christopher Steele who they fired as
a trusted source and they used falls
completely unverified never corroborated
a dossier he put together to get a
warrant and then spy on the Trump
campaign never tell the judges she paid
for it and in the process lying to FISA
Court judges on four separate occasions
never revealing Hillary paid for all
this this is the biggest abuse of power
corruption scandal we have seen in the
history of this country
talk about Watergate this is Watergate
on steroids and human growth hormone
Watergate what a third-rate break-in
that eventually forced the President to
resign you may remember this to continue
the fight through the months ahead for
my personal vindication but almost
totally absorbed the time and attention
of both the president
and the Congress in a period when our
entire focus should be on the great
issues of peace abroad and prosperity
without inflation at home therefore I
shall resign the presidency effective at
noon tomorrow
what is playing out right now is nothing
compared to Watergate